i tried to sit back as far as i could so
there'd be a long awkward silence
thank you to dr arn the platform party
family and friends
and to the class of 2015 congratulations
we made it
before i begin my speech i find it
appropriate to brag on behalf of this
class to all of you here
the class of 2015
is the smartest class ever admitted to
hillsdale college
and as of last night it is also the most
philanthropic
last summer the other class officers and
i set a goal for 50 percent class
participation in our give back campaign
and according to my count we've reached
our goal
once we finalize these pledges several
generous alumni will help us establish a
scholarship for next year's incoming
freshmen as a token of our love for this
place
and uh and one more note
two years ago
at r.a training dr aaron made a deal
with matt o'sullivan that if he kept his
four point dr arn would buy him any book
up to a certain amount
and as matt is too humble to say this
for himself i feel obligated to remind
the good doctor of this
so
matthew what was the amount
100
i'm losing money like crazy so
so send me an email and remind me and
i'll send you the book for the hundred
dollars the um
i made a bet with jack babbitt he's
gonna watch this tape
and he gave a big gift for the chapel
and with the architect sitting there and
with rich payway sitting there he said
you'll never build this chapel
for this amount it's going to cost four
times as much
and i said in a rash moment
i bet you
five thousand dollars to your favorite
charity against five thousand dollars to
mind that we can build it for that and i
looked at rich
and i looked at
the architect and they both nodded their
heads
and i'm getting ready to write a check
to jack babbitt for five thousand
dollars
now it's five thousand one 100.
thank you dr arn
when i began to write this speech last
night
i'm really glad you all thought that was
a joke
i considered several different
approaches after all
what is one supposed to talk about in a
commencement speech
should i reflect on the last four years
here
reminiscing about the highlights of my
experience
an attempt to generalize them so that
everyone might identify
not to say that there's anything wrong
or at all inaccurate about remembering
those nights when the cell phones go
silent the laptops are shut tight and
the conversation amongst friends soars
far and wide
after all it is true that most of us if
not all of us have had those experiences
and that is a good thing
but this is a commencement address
for a while now i have found it odd that
we call the graduation of seniors in the
spring commencement dr ward pointed this
out
commencement refers to a beginning
to make a start or enter in upon
something
yet we are concluding our education here
and our time has come to an end
of course many of you probably want to
respond with but our education never
ends to which i'd respond you're right
now shut up i'm giving the speech
so why do we name the ceremony marking
our departure from the school this place
in these people in terms of a beginning
well i have a theory
commencement is an attempt to give this
moment a particular significance
in a conscious manner we want this
moment of transition to be one of hope
and of promise a setting out from home
and confidence and joy towards some
glorious fate
this day is the first day of the rest of
our lives and four years here have
prepared us to meet it with bright eyes
and full hearts
if only that were true
in order to make us even more
self-conscious about what is happening
right here right now i'll tell you how
i'm actually
am terrified
the last time that i was this terrified
was one thousand three hundred fifty
days ago
august twenty eight two thousand eleven
in our freshman convocation
i'll be honest with you
like many here today i had not wanted to
come to hillsdale in fact it was my last
choice
some of you including my family knew
that
but until now i've never told anyone the
real reason why
it wasn't because of pride or
stubbornness or some other pretended
thing
i didn't come to this school because i
was terrified
terrified to fail
terrified to succeed
terrified of the unknown
this college is hard what we do here is
difficult from beginning to end without
exception
and the worst part is that it is
completely up to us to do it
sure we have the support of so many
wonderful people
but the fundamental responsibility lies
with us
the words of albert camus from dr
jackson's great books class come to mind
i didn't know that freedom is not a
reward or a decoration that is
celebrated with champagne
nor yet a gift a box of dainties to make
you look your chops
oh no it's a chore on the contrary and a
long distance race
quite solitary and very exhausting
at the end of all at the end of all
excuse me
freedom is a court sentence
that's why freedom is too heavy to bear
especially when you're down with a fever
or are distressed
or love nobody
1 350 days ago we stood together at east
lawn
and at the prompting of dr arn we faced
our parents and loved ones hugged them
and walked up to that hill to find those
mentor groups we now laughingly
remember and we began our journey
today 1 350 days later we find ourselves
together again
and today
i'm still terrified
terrified to fail terrified to succeed
terrified of the unknown
and terrified because i'm about to leave
the best friends for which a man could
ever hope
last year josh andrew asked on this
occasion was it worth it
this year i asked the question is that
whatever we are leaving this for worth
it
and my answer is simple
yes and no
no because a few of us just a few of us
will ever have another chance to study
these great things to spend our days in
leisure and contemplation and enjoy the
immediate presence of friends engaged in
the same activity of soul
not to mention that if we were to
continue all the stupid things we've
done here most of us would live in boxes
without a prospect of a real job
and i say yes
that whatever is out there is worth
leaving this for
because we were never meant to stay here
the hard truth of this college is that
we live and learn here for a short time
during which we are formed and molded to
live in the world
we are called from here to love and to
teach others
to show them the beauty that we have
been shown to suffer and struggle and do
the difficult activity of living
often it will be thankless
often it will be suffering
always though
it should be joyous
we are called and we must respond
the funny thing about what we are doing
here today is that no matter how hard we
try no matter how flowing our robes are
or how many pictures we take we cannot
give this day meaning
but that isn't to say that today isn't
significant because in a very real way
this is the most significant day of our
lives
for the first time in four years we are
gathered together in one place
we've all grown and flourished in a
variety of astounding ways
so this moment is not significant
because of the robes or the pictures or
because we want it to be
the significance and overwhelming
meaning of this moment right here right
now
is not the result of our conscious
choice to make it so
but comes from all our experiences until
now
and now we stand at the end of this
journey
staring into what may seem to be an
abyss but this abyss should not terrify
us but give us hope
because in its darkness is not futility
and nothingness but endless possibility
for greatness
the unknown is just that
unknown
we can only choose how we greet it with
fear and trembling
or with wonder
so i return to the words of camus
at the end of all freedom is a court
sentence
that's why freedom is too heavy to bear
especially when you're down with a fever
or are distressed
or love nobody
and i think that this is right because
after four years here we have found
freedom to be a chore it has been a long
distance race at times quite solitary
and very exhausting and far too heavy to
bear
this is the fate to which we have
dedicated ourselves and our commitment
to this college
and to each other
but here at the end of it all this
realization is the moment to which our
education has led us
to recognize the difficulty of what we
have chosen to to do and not merely to
face it but to thrive in the face of it
we have not simply overcome suffering
we have been formed by it for a future
far more glorious than any we can
conceive
we need only look back at those men and
women who helped raise us
our parents
for a model of this
consider what it means to bear a child
bringing into this world new life a
helpless and vulnerable person for whom
you are wholly responsible this burden
is terrifying
they are here today not because of fear
for responsibility but out of love for
the life that they have helped form and
in the process been formed by
they recognize the beauty of this moment
not because it isn't
a moment without strife and despair
but they recognize the beauty of this
moment
because they've been they've persevered
through those things
and they have learned to love
that which is true and good
from this moment forward we will share
in this beauty and not because it isn't
suffering or pain or struggle but
because through those things our hearts
and souls have been formed to a greater
love of that which is good and beautiful
after all
one sees clearly only with the heart
anything essential is invisible to the
eyes
so today i thank god and i thank all of
you
because we know that this freedom we
undertake is not too heavy
we love just as we are loved
and we have the people around us today
our family
our friends
and each other
to thank for that
as we gather here together again
i have faith this love will
abide through it
we will know beauty
and through it
we have a hope that leads us beyond the
confines of this world
you